Voiceover:Let's explore what it means
to subtract numbers.
So let's say that I want to figure out
what 4, what 4 minus 3 is.
4 minus 3.
So one way to think
about this, is you start
with 4 objects.
And so let me just draw 4 objects.
So there I have 1, 2, 3, and 4.
And when I ...
So this is the 4 objects right over here.
And when I say minus 3, or if I'm going
to subtract 3 from the 4, one way to think
about it is, I'm going to take 3
of these 4 objects away.
So let's do that.
So I'm going to take away 1, I'm going to
take away 2, and I'm going to take away 3.
Notice, I took away 1, 2, 3 objects.
So how many do I have leftover?
Well, if I start with 4 and I take away 3,
I subtract 3, 4 minus 3, I am left
with, I am left with, 1
object, right over here.
So 4 minus 3 is equal to, is equal to 1.
Fascinating.
Let's do another one of these.
Let's figure out what 5,
what 5, what 5 minus 2 is.
And let's write it this way.
Let's say we want to figure out something,
some question mark, some question mark ...
Actually, let me just clear this out.
I'll just do it right over here, actually.
So let's say we have some question mark.
So there's some unknown
number right over here.
So I'll just put a
question mark over here.
And we say that unknown
number is equal to,
is equal to 5, 5 minus 2.
Minus 2.
So what is this going to be?
Well let's visualize it.
This means I have 5 things and I'm going
to take away 2 of them
and this is going to be
what I have leftover after I start with 5
and take away 2.
So I have 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 things.
Now I am going to take away 2 of them.
So I'm going to take away 1 and 2.
So I took away 1, 2 objects.
So how many do I have leftover?
Well, I have leftover these, these ...
Let me do this in a different color.
I have leftover these purple
things right over here.
So how many is that?
How many do I have leftover?
Well, I have leftover 1,
2, 3 of my original 5.
So something is equal is 5 minus 2.
That something is 3.
3 is equal to 5 minus 2.
Let me just replace this with a 3.
So we see that 3 ...
Actually, let me do
the 3 in the same color
as this green.
So we see that 3, 3 is equal to 5 minus 2
or we could say that 5
minus 2 is equal to 3.
Either way.